[Music]
all right
what happened
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
here what's going on you guys Lord ax
here there's no audio for a couple
seconds I forgot to unmute everyone my
bad uh what we were saying is uh we're
gonna have a little bit of a rocky step
going in for a little bit because we
have have to fix some of the issues that
because here's the thing OB I was using
OBS uh obs
I think it's called like it's pretty
much where I invite King on as a guest
but there's issues where sometimes I
couldn't hear him
I don't get no issues like that when we
on Zoom
and you know why because I think it's
Microsoft owns them
Microsoft owns teams
I don't know if they ever owned Zoom
right I said I was giving them credit
for something that ain't even have
yeah what you tend to do sometimes
before he going into that yes but I
appreciate it for coming through to the
r r we talk about
movies TVs and Anime you know there's
yeah we got we got some stuff going on
you got a static background
i i s it's working fine on my end
no they talking about your background is
is nothing like going on there that's a
static background so like that's why it
looks like he's in the only fans
you know people keep saying that what
I'll probably do eventually is like put
something up here you can put his green
screen behind him and do funky things
you don't want to do it
hey I could do that couldn't I yes you
can
I wonder what kind of funky things I
could do
we talked about a lot of funky things
[Laughter]
but I appreciate everyone coming through
you know we we actually got a lot
talking about right now
we we're going to be talking about Mario
we're going to be talking about uh
Dungeons and Dragons and we're also
going to be talking about uh oh he said
you got background audio hold on let me
hear Let me see
yep we talked about a lot of funky
things plug it up yeah I think one of
your uh things got loose in your deck
we're coming through you know with my
Dad yeah so you hear me twice no it
hears it sounds like um a machine
humming it's not as refrigerated
somebody said it's a refrigerator it's
just it sounds like either a bent or
loose wire
what about now
let me listen
testing
yeah
hello hello hello it sounds like um a
machine humming
very low
let me listen
and it's not mine
yeah
hello hello hello hello there you go
wrong
it's just
did it stop y'all no the hummus they
said the hump's still there yeah he said
it's his fish tank
oh my God there's always something with
audio man it never fails
all right let me see this
I saw I'm about to just have like a
straight up
episode over audio
somebody send me a car that's crazy it
feels like
from something
yeah that's what that's exactly what it
is is feedback
while you're worrying about that I gotta
worry about my code
all right
no it's still there I don't know what it
is
here but I do know here
I don't know what it is
they said there you go
yeah
okay
ah there it is see the the reason it's
disappearing is because I'm unhooking my
actual mic it's not going to be there if
it's unhooked yeah I'll look into it you
know I I made it worse
let me hear
hello
hello ah there it is see the reason it's
disappearing is because I'm unhooking my
actual mic it's not going to be there
I'll look into it you know I I made it
worse it's very low let me hear
it it said it's better now
all right very low
what about now can you guys hear it now
he said you gotta Echo now
all right what about now like I had to
Echo because I was monitoring it
low budget got a low Buzz we gotta find
out what the low Buzz is
yeah I don't think I'm gonna be able to
find it on the fly like that though
all right let's do the show man let's
get rid of this show
all right look guys you just the biggest
thing you'll have to like work with me
is just coming back uh from doing all
this I I gotta figure out what that is
maybe I I know I've been doing the
podcast just fine I I don't I don't know
what it is we'll figure it out there's
somebody's hating on RNR with the Lords
man because it's always on all with the
Lords we always having an issue and when
we get it together you're done son
you're done you hear me you're done son
yo attic let's let's go with a cabin in
the woods being I know that is your
least favorite situation
um knock at the woods yeah knock at the
woods knock at the cabin yeah let me fix
it yeah
I liked it
you like the knock at the cabin yeah I
liked it I don't know why
oh you got to tell yo all right so
listen guys I thought I was being funny
by telling attic to watch this joint
right definitely sabotage definitely
sabotage not
um but I'm like yo
I saw it I was like yeah I had to watch
this craziness I'm gonna have attic
watch this craziness
and there's an M night Sam a lot movie
we all know that he's known for weird
twists and turns in his films
um his reveals is like something crazy
and this this is on peacock right yes
this is on peacock so for y'all all you
guys that you know got peacock y'all can
go check this film out it came out in
the movie theaters I don't think it did
well
and um David Bautista stars in it and so
does the dude from um what's that um
Lord of the Rings no no not Harry Potter
right that's the dude from Harry Potter
that's in there with the red hair uh
he's in there so the film is it's it's
set in in the woods and
the main family
is a same-sex couple
what an adopted child
and uh so
the the two the same-sex couple is uh
Caucasian and the child is Asian
and
this it gets kind of crazy because the
little girl is sitting inside the forest
by herself
and then Along Comes Dave Bautista this
big man walks up on this kid and I think
he's gonna kill him as far as addict did
you think that he was going to kill his
kid in the forest
uh no it didn't seem like he was gonna
kill him like it it seemed it seemed
more of a like a communication barrier
if anything like they were just to
establish communication with the little
kid at the beginning what I like is like
you kind of think that little kid's
gonna start turning on people but it's
the other way around that little kid
tries to run late and what's funny is
they let that kid just run wild like
they they I think though the whole movie
they only they only tie that kid up one
time and that kid was doing some stupid
stuff the whole movie the whole movie I
mean it's it's a weird film in a sense
that
I really didn't know what expect to
expect I didn't know if all those things
was real
so again we don't want to go into
spoilers into the film because the film
is available for everybody to watch on
peacock right and I think you know if
you have Xbox or Playstation I think
they have a free trial of peacock you
can go check it out
um but it's something that's definitely
uh to pique your interest something that
you can definitely watch
um did you believe all that stuff was
real that's my only opinion you know um
question that I have for you at it I
feel like they intentionally made it to
where you didn't believe it at first
because they had like the pre-recorded
thing and you know yeah
this is the kind of movie that could
easily go the other way around
right where homeboy was manipulated the
whole time but for some reason I felt
like the way they were setting this up
it was like that intentionally so I kind
of they're in the towards like the
middle of the movie I kind of
started second doubting it right but
once especially you know there at the
end when he was like look at if you if
if you if you doubt it then you find out
all this damage and stuff like
it was good I really enjoyed it all
right so how many popcorn would you give
it I'll give it a three you give it
three I give it a three as well yeah I
think it was a solid movie I don't think
it's a movie theater movie
uh but I do think it's a you know
streaming service I do think it brings
value to streaming services I just don't
think it's a movie theater movie
yo Don is definitely right they got to
give M like movie stop giving them
movies to see uh movies it's definitely
a good peacock movie is a movie that's
for a streaming service it's not
something that you're gonna catch in a
movie theater
question
do you
you think and maybe it's just me
I'm actually starting to like Batista as
an actor
because of the different roles that he's
getting or because of I think he's
matured as an actor I think it's because
how he's mature as an actor and I think
he even knows he's gotten better more
potential than people giving credit for
because that's one of the reasons you
know he's been so vocal about leaving
Drax is because he doesn't like the bad
the you know the the kind of uh the type
casting of dead humor that dress has
yeah so I think you know he doesn't want
to be seen as that for his entire life
oh yeah Drax I mean Drax can definitely
the character itself doesn't have any
range because he's a dim-witted idiot uh
so the fact that he's playing characters
with range and emotion like this last
character that he played in this movie
now has a lot of range in a lot of
motion because he's a school teacher so
as a school teacher
he is conflicted with the stuff that has
to happen in his film especially with it
involving a child so you know and you
can see that conflict come across him as
a person so it's really good but Dave
Bautista where in Target or Walmart
clothes in the woods is definitely
something for y'all guys to see so yeah
it's definitely watch the watch I do
think you know we might actually have to
do a um
oh you got a super chat from uh yo mans
all right hold on all right yo free R
Kelly with the five dollar Super Chat
man ain't nobody going to see Guardians
three marbles washed up washed it's over
Sony is dominating with Spider-Man
um doesn't Spiderman
live in the Marvel Universe actually if
you want to get technical I would say
Marvel's made Spider-Man Hot yeah but
Spider-Man was always hard but I think
Marvel is what pushed it over to like
the highest stream of mainstream yeah I
mean they both needed each other Kells
cut it out
but I see I'm glad you showed up Kells
because you know I only thought they
only let you out on Sundays
he he asked for uh for every time I
think that's my boy to know
is that pronoun man let me double check
man because this is this I grew up with
him
and that is my dude let me let me see
let me see
black boxing Kings salute brother
yeah so I mean when it comes to
when it comes to knock at the woods I I
liked it I thought it was a solid
foundation of a movie I thought that I I
do think that they
they sped up the plagues that's all I'm
gonna say the plagues part too much I
felt like certain things happened too
quickly there was no build up to it
right but what I will say is you know
for what they had and what they done I
think I think it was uh it was it was
done well
I think they had to do it that way
I think they had to do it that way so
all right all right guys
addict didn't get the chance to see
Dungeons and Dragons yeah because attic
lives like an hour away from
from
a movie theater now so your local
scapegoat me King went to go see
Dungeons and Dragons I hear it's good
though I hear it it's getting a lot of
good praise it is I'ma drink my root
beer while you talk about it it's it's a
phenomenal movie it's it's dope because
if any of you guys like Boulder's Gate
and like Dungeons and Dragons and never
went to Knights and all that stuff
everything that you've ever loved about
those series are there
like uh from the big dragon they poke
fun at that to some of the the weapons
that are in the game they poke fun at
that the the Mages the warlocks the red
elves
um some of the lore that's there it's
it's all there and I think this is a
time where you know us as adults you
know we have grown up from reading these
books and playing these video games and
they're implementing all of this stuff
into the movies
um
the comedy is spot on I thought this was
going to be the ultimate Easter movie
right let's let's take Mario out of the
equation and if this was the only movie
to rock for Easter this was the movie I
was going to recommend you take your
children to go see it's um has a lot of
heart to it you know it had the the
chick from um Fast and the Furious in it
he had uh the dude that played Captain
Kirk in it you had the the other dude
from Pokemon that was in it
um and this movie is is just funny
it's it's it's it's witty it's funny has
a ton of humor and at the end
it has a lot of heart because you feel
for a lot of things and it it makes you
realize that some people uh because of
their circumstances they're putting in
unrealistic positions that you know they
got to work through it's a good film a
very very good film and it's a even
better film if you're a fan of Dungeons
and Dragons if you're down with the
board game so you played the video games
or you read the books you will be
enthused intrigued and you will have a
great laugh I was in a movie theater uh
and you know I took uh my wife and my
son to go see it and it was a guy in the
movie theater by herself watching it
normally that's me and then you know
because I gotta fulfill my request for
the week and he was laughing his behind
off and he was laughing at spots where
if you played the video game or you read
the books you knew certain things and he
got it when I got it and it was just you
know it was really good to see so I'm
definitely going to give this a full
popcorn
um from all the CGI from all the comedy
from everything you catch all the humor
you catch everything throughout the
movie I thought the movie was phenomenal
it's definitely something that y'all
going to enjoy so go see Dungeons and
Dragons give it a full popcorn
um
I don't know when Attica get a chance to
see it probably it'll come on uh HBO Max
or something like that yeah at this
point you know I I've looked into it
like you know
my movie theater shut down so the
nearest movie theater is is Beckley and
beckley's like 45 minutes an hour away
and then it's got a it's got a four
dollar toll between us and Them All
right so I pretty much if I go watch a
movie I gotta add that on to any movie I
watch at that point it's gas and food
yeah gas everything
so yeah attic is only going to really
realistically see all the big films
um so I'm really your your gopher your
guinea pig that's going to be checking
out all these um iffy films and
we have a ton of iffy films this whole
month of April from Renfield to the
Pope's Exorcist
and all the way down the line I am going
to go watch the evil dad movie oh yeah
and the Evil Dead uh yeah kind of scary
movies this month obviously some Marvel
I'm gonna go watch those
one Marvel comes what do we have
Guardians this month
um I don't know I don't think so I think
it's nice to see Tyler keeps me to up to
date with them things yeah I think
Guardians is next month I think
so yeah we'll definitely
be catching up on stuff like that I I do
want to watch Dungeons and Dragons and
you know oh you're gonna love it I I do
think it's like maybe
when I get free time it like go up there
and just watch a couple movies this same
time you know like movies back to back I
know that sounds like really rough for
people no I did that I did that yo shout
out to you for trying that if you can do
it I did uh we did a back to back the
only reason why we didn't do three
because I had my son with me and he you
saw him breaking down after the second
move
he ain't got it in him all right so we
do have a patreon question I always
check uh during the show just to make
sure no one says it at the last minute
hey yo we got 37 people hold on one
second addict with only 19 likes let's
get those likes up please yeah let's I
know it's going to take a little bit of
time for you guys to get used to we took
like a three-week uh vacation uh we had
PAX East was one of the weeks huh we
wasn't a vacation and we gave them
um R and R with the Lords we we did
Shazam and we did uh John Wick yeah yeah
obviously uh but you get what I'm saying
we haven't did the live show in like
three weeks yeah we back baby so we got
uh we got a patreon uh member chat from
J Boogie three two seven hey do you guys
know about the three episode Rule and
would you take three episode suggestions
based off of if you like it or not
um I don't know anything about the three
episode rule you know nothing about the
three episode rule uh you know some
people say you got to watch three
episodes or something before you can
actually say if it's good or bad
I'ma tell you this
do you need to take three bites of of
something to realize you don't like it
hell no okay okay I I'll give you that I
will give you most the time you can
determine in one episode if you're gonna
like a show or not but I will say there
are shows out there and there's a lot of
them
[Music]
uh I would say Demon Slayer is one of
them demons like you get into it quicker
but I would say Demon Slayer is also one
of those as well where you know you get
a couple episodes in and then it really
really picks up
so I do feel like there are exceptions
now when it comes to movies
that's different
uh I could I could tell you within 15
minutes if I'm a life of movie or not
uh because I feel like movies you have
less
room for error because you only in out
out
bless you
that that that's my opinion when it
comes to movies because they're you know
anywhere from an hour and 45 to two and
a half hours these days I feel like
you're getting more of the two to two
and a half hour marks than you used to I
usually you have to hit me the majority
of them in in movies you can't keep me
longer than I think it either because I
kind of felt like Avatar was a little
too long for myself yeah I thought
Avatar had a little long dead spots too
as well but you know that's James
Cameron you know you you you give him an
ad you allow afford them that you know
for his genius I guess yeah so would I
take away from
from the avatar for how it was doing
probably not I do think it was still a
good movie but you know I do think the
three rule exists and for the most part
especially TV shows and Anime
only exists when a fan is telling you to
watch something and you watch the first
episode and he was like nah be as trash
and he like yo hold on hold on boy give
it at least two more episodes because
you did that to me with Attack on Titan
and I'm not gonna lie
after those next couple episodes then it
heated up
I'ma give you that
so but other than that
I don't know I think you can argue that
you need at least two to three episodes
for Death Note too
because the First episodes pretty like I
think when Death Note really takes off
is when care is on TV and he TR and L
tricks him into killing someone else I
think that's when that show really takes
off and that's like three episodes in
it's just I feel like there is some
episode seasons and some uh like I said
movies a little bit different but
especially TV shows an anime where
the show's okay but it escalates a
couple episodes in
So you you're gonna have uh Sovereign
watch Death Note right yes eventually
I'm going to have him watch that though
it will be on our patreon
um right now I think I'm gonna have him
watch another uh another fight just to
get him a little bit first off we gotta
figure out what happened with Mike I
don't know what I don't know what that
was about yeah because he recorded on
his own yo something is going on
somebody jinxed that's what I might be
yeah we were doing fine until packs we
were doing fine no we got that I did
listen it did seem like my my vibing
issues over I didn't hear it this time
okay uh so I unplugged it plugged it
back in regardless I'm still gonna
unplug everything and plug it back in
just to make sure
uh because these mics are too expensive
not to be working correctly that's right
that's an expensive joint right there
all right all right King we we gotta
talk about it you know and for those of
you that don't realize that oh I haven't
really messed with anything in the
middle normally I have like pictures and
stuff going up in the middle uh but
right now currently I'm not able because
the steam deck's not working correctly
um I don't know what's going on with it
it is what it is
Mario Super Mario Brothers
gotta
you gotta tell me man what what was
first off let's let's back it up what
was your expectations going into Super
Mario Brothers
after seeing the trailer
my expectations were
Nintendo is going to save video game
movies
that was my expectations after watching
the trailer
my because
video game movies and this is Dungeons
and Dragons aside because remember
Dungeons and Dragons I saw that first
that was on the high note I'm like yeah
they here
and you know Sonic was pretty good
um but they they hit the like eight
right don't ever hit the 10 never break
through the ceiling
um
and it's always they're good but you
know movie theaters is always like
they're good but
you know uh and people would be like
yeah they're good but you know that's a
video game
not this one bro
it's my expectations on this one was
Nintendo gotta save us
and I think you can
think you can argue that they uh
they they kind of did you know I'm not
gonna say that this is the best
adaptation that's ever been in gaming
but I'm saying
is good
it's I I personally have an issue of how
they handled Bowser to a degree
yeah look I'm never saying that that
wasn't what they always betrayed
going through the years but I would say
they did it in a better way in the past
where he was definitely a simp but you
wouldn't know it you know what I'm
saying like and maybe it's because
a narrative's never been the front the
Prime Focus when it comes to a Mario
game but you know what
I gotta really say man
the Easter eggs on this movie
it's like how many do you think what's
the over and under oh okay I say there's
at least 50. okay so you said 50. 50 and
higher I'm gonna say
it's more than a hundred
and you might be right I wouldn't be
surprised that was the only reason why
I'm gonna say it's more than 100 because
I know my motto is a stickler for
numbers
you got 99 coins
you know you get 99 lives
I know he's gonna go
for a hundred because you can jump over
the flag 100. what was your you know
we'll get a little bit in the spoiler
territory here guys what was your
favorite uh favorite Easter eggs in this
the
Super Punch Out Pizza
remember that one because that was the
logo for the pizza shop the pizza shop
was called Super Punch Out Pizza all
right my second one was Jump Man
the arcade machine all right so Nintendo
had a problem in the beginning because
they couldn't use the name Donkey Kong
because some other company had the name
Donkey Kong so they was going to come
out with a game called Jumpman and that
was supposed to be Mario jumping over
the thing well they got the rights to
whatever Donkey Kong or whatever and I
might be saying this wrong please don't
cap uh uh you know uh you know capture
this I know they had a problem with the
name and they wind up with their first
name was going to be was going to be
Jump Man wind up being Donkey Kong but
on the arcade cabinet
it says Jump Man
and I was just I was smiling for
absolutely no reason I I was smiling for
the majority of the movie I have to
honestly like be honest with that you
know I I liked that some of my favorite
one was when they're on obviously
there's a there's a a cart section in
the game you know very Easter egg is
towards Mario Kart and I like when
they're taking on this particular person
the entire time when they finally get
this man dealt with so he ain't done he
comes out and he says you'll never beat
me and he's like blue shell
yo I lost it I lost it I started I
started dying laughing when he said that
like straight up started dying laughing
when he said that
and it was dope too what he did
yeah no my joints was when when they got
to the Luigi off on his own and showed
how frightened he was but it
automatically went to Luigi Mansion do
you think that spins off of Luigi's
Mansion movie
it could only they did everything that
they did
so Mario franchise a Mario Kart movie
yes
Cranky Kong
yeah that he was he he was the king you
thought King Kong you thought Donkey
Kong was going to be the king
I kind of did I kind of expected him not
to be the king because you saw him
fighting in the commercial and it didn't
look like they would put him on the
crown like that you know what I'm saying
uh but man when Donkey Kong came out
there tell me when you heard that Donkey
Kong
you've only heard that in one game like
one game that was the N64 Donkey Kong
game yep
it was just remember when he yelled out
sit down Diddy
I was actually thinking myself when I
was watching I wonder if Diddy Khan uh
and um I can't remember all their names
but they all were there if you look at
him he only addressed Diddy calm but the
others were standing beside him Dixie
and everybody was there
it was good man I like when they went to
pick up the cards right
and I forget which one it was I think it
was um I think it was Mario Kart 64.
when you when you got the gliders I
think that was the one I I correct me if
I'm wrong that was the only time you you
got this slide because that's when the
motorcycle showed up and you was able to
pick like your glider your wheels and
your frame
and when they went up to it and they got
there and they did the glider the the
frame and the wheels
and they picked a cart
yo I lost it I absolutely I was smiling
the entire time that they were picking
it because it showed the in the uh the
the the the Wii U and the switch yup UI
that they scored right down to get it
it's like look like I get it like if
you're not a gamer you're not gonna
really enjoy this movie to the fullest
but I got a question why are you
watching this if you're not a gamer
but if you're going to watch this and
you're not a gamer and you're not being
drugged to this thing by gamer why are
you watching this
yo
because it was Easter
and this is the ultimate Easter film
let's get let's put our hands together
let's put our hands together
for the greatest CGI that I've seen I
know Disney right now is quaking in
their boots they're probably Frozen
because I I think
I think if Nintendo
sits down with some really good
storytellers and some good writers they
can demolish all in attendance they
could take all Disney Stacks when it
comes to animation yeah they can go
right at them go go straight like
imagine imagine if they go
they bring Yoshi in the second one right
you saw him when he was running around
no I didn't wait okay so you didn't see
where they was going from um from the
sand place to the other place and then
they ran past and he showed the Yoshis
running in herds no I I didn't catch
that oh my God and the pink Yoshi looked
over at him was like
and then kept going yeah so imagine they
they go into
Zelda right then they go into Donkey
Kong a movie around the Donkey Kong uh
region then they can go into like Icarus
yo hold on uh Nintendo Taco with a 10
super chat Mario is the most video game
is the most video game video game movie
that is its best qualities it's in its
works the pacing was way too fast paced
which is like a Mario game but it's
still enjoyable from beginning to end
yeah and you know what I enjoy too is
okay I I get it some people
how do you think they portrayed Peach
I thought Peach was crazy I thought I
thought I thought she was okay she's the
VIP of the show the movie was she
supposed to be because okay in every
game they she's the the focal point
right
we want to know why Bowser captures are
we want to know why Mario goes and gets
them but that kind of turned on its head
when you got to Super Mario 64 and you
saw Peach's castle all right so you see
Peach's castle now you come to find out
that she is uh like the she's the
princess of the land and you really have
to told people if you if you go into the
to the the cartoon and stuff like that
okay
later on when he was playing Mario Kart
and she had the bike
she was dope
so they kind of leaned into the
character and gave her more personality
and more presence opposed to letting
Mario
exactly they took away that whole
weakness I loved what they did with her
because I felt like she's always been
there and little sprite goes throughout
the game but they've never done a good
job explaining she's useful but in this
they explained it she grew up with uh
with them she she learned how to fight
through a lot of them like she like when
they were like don't go to d uh don't go
to Donkey Kong's country they ain't like
no forget that we go
you know what I like
I like told
I like that that that
told that mushroom guy
was different from all the other ones
because he was like I told you I'm not
leaving because you said yo listen go
find someplace safe let's go you know
Bowser is here right now he was like yo
I told you I'm not leaving
and she was like wow finally uh uh a
mushroom with courage
and he's completely different
Nintendo on their Taco with the five
dollar Super Chat everybody needs to
apologize to Chris chat because he did a
good job everyone did good except for
Anya's speech her performance was phoned
in in my opinion yo I told people before
when it was flipping out about Chris
Pratt I like them he sounded great
I said let's see the film you know what
I like too they made the dad have that
accent
yep yo you know what I like even more
the guy that was playing Donkey Kong
inside the uh the pizza shop
was a parody of the original Super Mario
movie
you know the dude who played in the live
action
he was wearing the same exact get up and
he was a parody of that guy and he said
yeah you should have uh uh a plumber and
it should have a Whatchamacallit voice a
Super Mario uh uh
um Italian voice it was really good uh
Killian brown with the two dollar Super
Chat uh mag said Nintendo's doing the
ncu I hope to God that they are yeah
I hope they actually take time and do it
right that's the biggest thing I hope
they take time and do it right because
what I saw is something that that Disney
has never been able to do
is
be able to combine their properties like
that like oh yeah just think about it
the first Mario movie in a long time you
know I don't even count the first one
the first Mario movie they introduced
they introduced Donkey Kong
they introduced Bowser they introduced
uh Yoshi Yoshi uh keeping my warrior
still not here they said Mario galaxies
Mario Galaxy because the uh the Stars
was in the game in the movie tell me how
that star in the volcano wasn't funny
man I loved that yep
you know I'm telling my girl because
she's watching with me she never played
these games and I'm like that star
that's stronger than anything in this
show right now this movie right now
she's like no I'm like yeah people don't
realize that star there can get out of
this situation if he wanted to exactly
finally
[Laughter]
he was so morbid it was dope oh man it's
such
I I can't overstate this
the CGI is some of the best CGI you are
going to see and it took Nintendo
to get it right and just like Nintendo
was the Savior for the video game
franchises and consoles all the console
war and we got now all the stuff that we
were able to do because Atari killed it
Nintendo you know what's crazy if you
really think about it King
they they obviously have their
individual people they can make a Wario
movie they can make uh whatever the
Luigi dude is that one they can make
they can bring him into it uh they can
also go and he's called
Waluigi they can go into the general
thing that you would think they would go
to making a you know a Mario sequel
making a Zelda movie they can make a
Donkey Kong Donkey Kong Sequel and then
they have these little side pockets they
can make a Mario Kart movie they can
make a Mario Party movie like like
imagine them making a Mario party but
it's like escape room
like there is so much that Nintendo can
do with this franchise it's not even
funny and that's if they don't want to
reach into unrealistic by pre-metron
people like that into the game well you
know they have a ton of of ips
and you can get Star Fox you can get all
these IPS into it but this movie from
beginning to end and I know it's kind of
short and you know like I told my wife I
could see this movie a million times I
don't care because if it wasn't and I if
if I still had the AMC thing and there's
an AMC around me I would have watched it
again
yeah I'm gonna go see it again this week
anyway uh we got Mr Joanna Dart what's
up brother yo I he he came out he's he's
always outside you know with the five
dollar Super Chat salute to you
gentlemen could Nintendo launch the
Mario Kart movie alongside a new game
could Nintendo do what Xbox and Sony
can't do with their games
yes and it would so well it was so
extremely well yes but I I don't want
them oh I don't want them to be held to
us unrealistic yeah uh like launch date
like where something has to sacrifice
either the game has to sacrifice so the
movie has to sacrifice I agree with you
the only way I would be okay with them
doing that is that they put enough time
aside for both to do them at the same
time to have them simultaneously come
out I don't want one being rushed for
the other exactly that's exactly what I
feel that's exactly
because I want a Metro he said I would
like a Punch Out movie in the vein of
creed yo they had so many little Easter
eggs you saw the f-zero in the back and
if you look at the photos the movie was
set in the 80s if y'all didn't look at
Mario's radio
it was incredible let me hold on we got
Dragonheart yo be my guy with the five
dollar Super Chat peace love life going
to see Mario and John Wick tomorrow
they are coming in full today man we
really appreciate that guy I do
appreciate it yeah because pretty much
everything r r makes goes straight back
into us watching movies at this exactly
like we we try we try our hardest to to
not take from the IOP Bank we try to we
try to fund ourselves okay basically I
mean and and what y'all did was just
send us to the movies this week and uh
get get a chance to see whatever new
comes out because I'm definitely going
to talk about Renfield
um there's a couple of movies that's uh
coming out this month a ton of movies
this month that uh you know my Regal
pass and I I I'm a starch supporter for
the Regal pass or the AMC pass if you
can get a movie pass and your active
moviegoer
go check it out
um who do it if I had a movie theater
like the one that was in Boston I would
go watch movies every weekend
yo attic fell in love with the movie
theater out there and it was his first
time going to Adobe Vision Adobe audio
movie theater it was uncomfortable it
was uncomfortable that's how I've never
been to anything like that the seats are
big you know big guy seats so me and
attic were sitting right next to me keep
in mind this is after we've walked an
entire day we are exhausted and I sat in
that thing and it was like it was like
sitting in a cloud
it was good man it was good you know we
we got a couple more things that we're
gonna to watch uh I am going to make
sure I watch
maybe one more movie this month you know
because I I got that 45 minute to an
hour and you know it's just a lot like
it's it's an entire day thing like two
hours there and back
the two to three hours for the movie
depending on what we're watching uh you
know considering that's a higher
tier movie theater the movie the tickets
are more expensive which is worth it
it's better than what I had you know
they actually have nachos and cheese not
that nonsense AMC has legit nachos
and cheese yo listen attic was so over
the moon with the Boston movie theater
and and listen
I saw John Wick in Dolby vision and I
saw John Wick and IMAX
Adobe Vision blew it away
the sound everything I'm I'm sorry IMAX
I think Dolby Vision just ate your lunch
but yeah
um but this Mario movie
attic
they got five popcorn
it's got five for me too like it just
it's not much I'll give a five
but man this
this move if I can give you more I'll
give it more
I only got nitpicks I don't got nothing
serious wrong with it just small little
nitpicks
and I'm a very
very
fine detail kind of person right and the
fact that I came out of this movie like
damn near perfect
like it was that good it was that good I
felt like everyone had their shine even
people like DK that you wouldn't think
would have that much screen time felt
like he was on the screen just as long
as Mario
yep
and it was it was
I I I don't know it just felt like it
made me feel like a kid again it made me
feel like the 80s again it made me feel
like when I had got my regular Nintendo
and oh remember when they was like uh
they was trying to fix their car and one
dude was like oh mine isn't working my
card isn't working he said why don't you
gotta blow on it a little bit
I just fell out it's just little things
like that
I'm like this and I know pause all right
for everybody out there you little
freaks
um
it's just it has so much fast service I
want to see this on digital so I can
just rewind it and I can just you know
like dissect the movie and find out all
the little Easter eggs but five popcorn
for me it's something that y'all should
go see uh the water is done perfectly
remember that's that the first time you
saw a wave race
and you said to yourself like yo how did
Mayo motto and these guys do this how
did they get the water physics to be
like this and it was the first time that
y'all saw that in the video game
and I'm not saying that this is the
first time I saw water move like that
but this is the first time water was
seamlessly integrated with CGI that I
didn't see any uh artifacts or anything
breaking up it was just really well done
well
and you know it's like one of those
things where
it's like if this is what you have to
offer Nintendo come and take Disney's
lunch money like I give it a four pacing
was too bad for me I feel that I I feel
like the pacing was pretend to order a
taco with the two dollars uh Super Chat
thank you but like here's my thing with
the pacing it wasn't bad pacing was just
fast-pacing they did everything they
were supposed to maybe they could have
made the fight between DK and and um
DK Mario a little bit better yeah maybe
they could have done that a little bit
better but even though that there are
some things that I feel like they could
have expanded on I can't say that they
didn't do it right you know what I'm
saying like yeah I can't say that what
they did wouldn't be good enough for me
yeah well he said four popcorn but the
Payson
foreign
it's I think that's fair though four
popcorns damn near perfect yeah it is
but
you know what no I you know I can't I
can't go against somebody else's opinion
of how they felt that the movie did for
them right you know I can only just talk
about my opinion of something and I
could just respect his opinion and
invalidate his opinion that way and I
respect his opinion uh pixel bit G with
the two dollar Super Chat the water with
sea of Thieves plus plus level loved it
that's what I'm talking about see I I
want to know I wanna I wanna see it
again to make sure that I'm not bugging
because when you had the light source
and and when it was going down in the
water when when Donkey Kong was going
down in the water
I lost it and they had to break through
the water at the top it
it was if it really looked very good
like and I said man these are spots
where you can make a breaker film when
you get from uh dry land and then you go
into water or you do ice and it's not
done well or you do fire and it's not
done wrong it's just all of it was just
done really really well
and it's worth it you know the acting
was really good I mean it was good
you're muted to
just go watch it guys at this point you
know we got a two dollar subscription
picks of it gee oh yeah you already said
that uh
it's good movie man it's good movie uh
you know there has been little things
going on we'll probably approach that
next week you know uh by next week we'll
probably have a decent amount on the
Mandalorian to talk about yes sir we'll
get to more this this week's kind of
more of a movie week now I do think what
I'm going to start doing is
um
kind of doing what we did like the road
to packs East thing but just give you
guys a little uh
little things to to look forward to I
think I'm gonna start you know for every
50 to 100 I don't know that uh r r gets
I think we'll start doing more of uh you
know raiding shows rating movies rating
TVs rating actors
you know that'll be fun we got a um a
community stream this weekend or
something like Saturday Saturday yeah
yeah we got one this Saturday and we're
gonna start bringing back you know fight
night Fridays boy I'll put these hands
on this guy over here with the Nora too
sure
yeah I like this my girl bought this for
me actually I like it I like it I like
it a lot I like it a lot she bought she
bought herself one too
we got we got it you got matching shirts
no matching shirts and uh matching uh
joggers they have the same Naruto thing
on them you got you gotta you gotta take
a picture
I think we did take babe did we ever
take a picture of us in the Naruto stuff
what did we ever take a picture of us in
the Naruto stuff
he said no but I I know where they are
so we could do that all right but that's
pretty much it for the show now um let
me go ahead and close this you ready for
attacking the black John
that's what's up so like I said you guys
want to see more of uh our content you
know definitely go to our patreon we
actually have some stuff coming up for
you guys uh King's about to start back
up on the attack on Titan we're gonna
record a couple of those episodes and
um we actually I have solved reaction to
stuff now I think some of you saw he
reacted to uh a Demon Slayer fight which
was pretty interesting
he's I think I'm gonna have him react to
another Demon's life I probably slept a
little early because he saw he saw right
Goku fight uh now I'm gonna think I'm
gonna show him one of the earlier fights
that's good where it's uh Tundra
fighting so we'll go from there uh Kings
doing the attack on Titan uh I've
finished the my hero I got it you gotta
let him do the whole pain series though
it's the whole pain series yo Obito oh
my God
see how I want to do it with him since
he's so oblivious and he's going
straight into the fight is I want to
write up a little brief summary of
what's going on like not not too
detailed but it's like this is Naruto
these are his abilities this is pain
these are his abilities here's a brief
summary of what's going on why they're
fighting push play you know what I'm
saying do you see the hypocrisy here
ladies and gentlemen
this guy took me an infant and threw me
into the ocean and said if we make it
home you make it home if he dies he dies
hey you guys
watch
every episode he he came back to me and
said you watched all 500. I said yeah he
said wait he was tired he was real tired
yo he said you didn't go through the the
you know there's a filler list I said
now I don't care about that
me and Grace watched the first 10
seasons of Naruto and then she's like
well okay we got to go to 11 it's like
no we're going to like I'm not I'm not
watching 11 12 13 14 15 because all that
[__] is Fiddler yeah but it was good
feeling to me and and this weekend I
just saw the will of fire I just watched
the will of fire which I thought was
dope which one was that is that the one
where cacao with the the KK genkai's
yeah they can't get game guys and um
my wife was so mad at it because she was
like they taking eyeballs
and I told her about Obito and how Obito
um is going to come back later and and
get his revenge so yeah let's go it was
good yeah so it's gonna be interesting
man it's gonna be interesting I think
you guys are going to really enjoy what
we got in store because we got some
really good stuff for you guys but this
is Lord king and the Lord addict and we
will come at you guys hopefully me and
King can get through a couple episodes
of Attack on Titan because I I think
there's some things in Attack on Titan
season two that I'm dying to hear King's
reaction to it yeah yeah peace peace
y'all thank you and thanks for all the
super chats we really yeah we really
appreciate that see with numbers like
that you know you got we got a super
chat up a little bit our viewership a
little bit when we have those monthly
interviews like [__] you know here
here's the numbers
success yes we are successful sir please
leave us alone we'll see you next month
see ya peace guys thank you
[Music]
foreign